ich habe drei monate komplett auf zucker
und weißmehl verzichtet eigentlich weiß
jeder wie ungesund erzeugen ist aber
trotzdem könnte das einfach nicht sein
lassen aber wie auch industriezucker zum
beispiel steckt so gut wie in allen
lebensmitteln drin und macht uns ähnlich
werden drogensüchtig und ich bin dann
auch eher so ein mensch der dann er
direkt ganze packung süßigkeiten weg
atmet bevorzugt die tiere sich meine
freundin gekauft hat er das schon
hunderte male gehört schlechte ernährung
unter anderem zu viel zucker und
weißmehl ist für mehr todesfälle
verantwortlich als jeder andere
risikofaktor auf der welt es hängt euch
bestimmt auch schon aus den ohren
heraushören dass in diesem joghurt
sieben stück würfelzucker sind in diesem
jahr scola sogar zwölf uns dass der
durchschnittsdeutsche am tag ganze 32
stücke also 95 gramm ist aber laut
experten eigentlich nur acht essen
sollte aber was passiert wenn man das
wirklich durchzieht und nicht nur wenig
sondern keinen einzigen gramm zucker ist
zum beispiel gewöhnt man sich an die
süße und braucht immer mehr um den
gleichen kick zu erreichen wenn man
jetzt aufhört schmecken dann plötzlich
selbst ungesüßte sachen total lecker
circa lässt zwar kurzzeitig das
energielevel nach oben schießen aber
durch den schnellen abfallen danach ist
und dadurch insgesamt leistungsschwächer
was passiert denn jetzt mit meinem
energielevel wenn ich gar keinen zucker
mehr und mal ganz nebenbei bekomme ich
als zucker süchtiger eigentlich durch
einen kalten entzug entzugserscheinungen
dieses video wird unterstützt von anke
kaut kapitel 1 bedingungen also drei
monate lang 0 gramm zucker und weißmehl
klingt simpel aber wirklich gar nichts
ja kein weißmehl bedeutet keine normalen
nudeln kein normales brot keine pizza
döner lasagne bürger praktisch kein
gepäck und vieles mehr kein zucker
bedeutet natürlich keine schokolade und
gummibärchen aber auch keinen ketchup
marmelade softdrinks alles was
zuckerersatz wie zb maissirup oder kokos
blüten zucker enthält keine
fertiggerichte und keine plätzchen und
weihnachten
einen schwachen trost gibt es aber da
die meisten negativen eigenschaften von
zucker die ich vorhin aufgezählt habe
mit dessen auswirkung auf den
insulinspiegel zusammenhängen ist obst
weiterhin erlaubt da der fruchtzucker
darin ohne insulinausschüttung
verstoffwechselt werden kann
kapitel zwei wochen ein experiment
beginnt am ersten zehn 2020 wenige tage
zuvor eine henkersmahlzeit ein traum aus
weiß mehl und zucker an dieser stelle
auf jeden fall ein riesen shoutout an
die sophie während dieser 3 monate ohne
zucker und weißmehl buttergebäck
vanillekipferl zimtsterne
niederländische pancakes christstollen
und verdammt das schoko vollen gemacht
hatte ansonsten hat sie mich aber echt
cool unterstützt und sogar ein gutes
stück mitgemacht zusammen haben wir zum
beispiel auch das gekocht thomas ist
momentan gesundem und deswegen machen
wir jetzt ein vollkommen bürger
[Musik]
ich würde sagen wir fangen wir an mit
den bands mit dem brötchen
[Musik]
und derselbe trick also das weiß wie
durch vollkornmehl auszutauschen hat
auch bei flanken funktioniert heute
machen wir zusammen flammkuchen bis
weihnachten wie kann ich denn nicht wenn
ihr schon ständig ist ein
[Musik]
aber manchmal konnte ich eben nicht bei
so viel mit essen sondern musste selbst
zucker und weil es mir los kommen und
hier hat mir angeschaut das leben
deutlich einfacher gemacht wären gewürze
haben mich in diesen drei monaten echt
gerettet denn weißmehl und vor allem
bürger verstecken sich nicht nur in den
allermeisten verarbeiteten lebensmitteln
sondern auch in manchen von denen man
ist auf den ersten blick vielleicht gar
nicht vermutet und das hieß für mich
plötzlich viel mehr mahlzeiten selbst
zubereiten und kochen was echt nicht
meine stärke ist da kam cacau
tatsächlich genau richtig da sie nicht
nur klassische gewürze wie pfeffer salz
basilikum und oregano im sortiment haben
sondern auch unglaublich viele
gewürzmischungen mit denen auch ein
kochbuch wie ich total leicht ohne viel
nachdenken das essen lecker schummeln
kann zumal den lieblings
gewürzmischungen gehört zum beispiel das
früher alge wird weil man einfach eier
in die pfanne pack nach lust und laune
das zeug drauf stolz und ein lecker
essen hat über den link in der infobox
bekommt er jetzt zu eurer bestellung bei
angekaut noch ein zufälliges gewürz
gratis dazu
kapitel 3 auswirkungen
also blieb ich glaube viele leute haben
eine gewisse erwartungshaltung an den
verlauf eines solchen experiment hatte
ich auch jeder hat schon sieben tage
ohne zucker gesehen jeder hat drei
wochen ohne zucker gesehen die story ist
immer die gleiche
erstens die person ist schockiert weil
überall so viel zucker drin ist mainz am
anfang ist der verzicht total schwer
aber danach wird leichter wenn mehr
energie besserer schlaf ist alles
möglich und viertens die person ist auch
in zukunft weiterhin weniger zucker aber
ganz ohne geht eben nicht das will ich
alles gar nicht mal kritisieren aber
unterschiedlich hätten meine erfahrungen
nach drei monaten keinen zucker und kann
weiß mir eigentlich gar nicht sein
können denn erstens war ich leider schon
gar nicht überrascht davon dass die
moderne messen fast überall zucker drin
wenn ich fand's dann wiederum auch eben
gar nicht so schwer sagt zu finden die
halt eben keinen zucker zugesetzt haben
und jetzt direkt schon mal zweiter
der größte unterschied ich fand sony mal
wirklich schwierig auf zucker zu
verzichten das größte problem bei mir
und wahrscheinlich auch bei vielen
anderen ist es dass wenn man einmal
anfängt der was man nicht mehr aufhören
kann und dann halt auch einfach erstmal
gar nicht anzufangen ist auch einfach
leichter als joker in maßen zu essen
dann anzufangen und dann aber wieder
stehen zu müssen diesen windkraft
aufwand von ob ich es jemals total geil
ist und ich könnte einfach weitermachen
zu kirchweih ist auch damit und das ist
ja nicht so toll dass es mir dadurch
erspart geblieben und mein kleiner
effekt am rande sowohl das video eine
woche nur fleisch essen aber auch das
video eine woche für einen euro am tag
essen und sogar eine woche nur
lieferdienste waren für mich wirklich
unangenehmer als diese drei wochen ohne
zucker und auch ohne weiß mitte wobei
weißmehl auf jeden fall der größere
verzichtbar ist der zucker also nudeln
pizza alles andere leckere und der
dritte unterschied zu vielen die so ein
experiment schon mal gemacht haben ist
dass ich am ende nicht mehr energie
hatte dass ich mich nicht irgendwie
gesünder geführt hat dass ich nicht
besser schlafen konnte und ich hatte
auch keine entzugserscheinungen
eigentlich schon fast schade weil für
dieses video wird natürlich spannender
gewesen kapitel 4 fehltritte welche
sünden habe ich mir denn jetzt geleistet
na ja wisst ihr noch als ich gesagt habe
buttergebäck vanillekipferl zimtsterne
niederländische pancakes christstollen
ja da habe ich dann tatsächlich dieses
stück flammkuchen aus weißmehl probiert
von diesen plätzchen habe ich auch eine
hälfte abgebissen und auch eine gabel
vom stollen habe ich probiert und am
30.12 nach genau 90 tagen war dann
schluss weil an silvester
reden wir nicht drüber sagen wir so ich
habe vergessen kapitel 5 mein fazit auch
wenn brokkoli durch die fehlende
abstumpfung durch den zucker nicht auf
einmal total lecker schmeckt kleiner
spaß ich liebe brokkoli und auch wenn
sich nicht mal mein schlaf verbessert
hat das ist mir tatsächlich relativ egal
zucker und weißmehl sind langfristig wie
gesagt für mehr todesfälle
verantwortlich heisst jeder andere
risikofaktor auf der welt und ich konnte
dazu lange nicht nein sagen aber jetzt
konnte ich und es fühlt sich verdammt
gut an zu wissen dass ich auch ohne
dieses teufelszeug ausgekommen bin und
das ist für mich das wichtigste weil der
mensch kann nun mal sehr wohl ohne
zucker auskommen und alles andere ist
auch noch anzeichen von schwäche
wenn ihr euch jetzt auf marktwerten
idiot weg gekriegt irgendwas halbwegs
brauchbares zu essen zu machen
entscheidet auch gerne mal über den link
in der video beschreibung bei angekauft
vorbei da gibt's nämlich zur eure
bestellung zufällig ein gewürz gratis
dazu an cacau doch einige bio gewürze
und gewürzmischungen und natürlich auch
welche ohne zucker und das war für mein
experiment dann natürlich mega praktisch
also lasst euch das auf keinen fall
entgehen ich mache übrigens jede woche
ein selbstexperiment oder irgendein
anderes verrücktes projekt also wenn ihr
das nicht verpassen möchte abonniert
gerne diesen kanal und dann sehen was
man wieder macht's gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja